we are joined now by janice baker kenny
who took the stand as a witness in bill
cosby's
2018 trial she testified that she was
sexually assaulted by the actor in the
80s
and her lawyer gloria allred who
represents dozens of women accused
who have accused bill cosby of assault
good morning to you both
janice i want to start with you because
last night it was reported that you were
processing
this this latest turn of events what's
your reaction today and how are you
feeling
well good morning gail i'm still
processing everything that's going on i
i just need to remember now
and it's almost like a mantra for me
that he was
released on a legal technicality
and not because he's innocent he is not
innocent
he'll never be innocent and i need to
hold on to that
so what would justice look like to you
now
because he is claiming that he is
innocent he's claimed claiming that
justice has been
served
he's going to always claim he was
innocent that that story
has never changed but the 60 plus women
that have come
forward we all know the truth
so his legacy
his uh will never be
what it used to be so a little bit of
justice served there he did serve two
years a little bit of justice
in the fact that he is a disgraced
former america's dad um
and i can live with that gloria it's
anthony in your view
is is this decision a setback to the
metoo movement
no anthony i don't think it is at all
there are many women who
continue to come forward many
persons who allege that they are victims
for example
of r kelly of harvey weinstein
in los angeles of many other
figures and they women are now empowered
in the way they never were before
janice was very brave when she testified
i'm so proud of her
and it is you know a shock but it's also
very clear that the pennsylvania supreme
court
did not make a decision that mr cosby
did not do what he was accused of doing
it was
based on a legal technicality on issues
of
due process and it was not based
on the merits and the evidence as to
whether he did it or not actually to the
contrary
the court talked about the statements
that mr cosby made in the deposition
in the civil lawsuit brought by andre
constant and called those statements
incriminating gloria you represent an
accuser in california who's filed a
civil case against bill cosby
does this decision affect that case in
any way
it does actually because now
that he is a free man now that he cannot
be
retried he cannot claim
uh or invoke his fifth amendment
privilege
against uh incrimination and and decline
to testify
uh in our civil lawsuit which alleges
that
our client judy huth uh was uh
victimized
was a victim of child sexual abuse by mr
cosby
at the playboy mansion we
have an order compelling him to sit for
a second deposition the first is under
seal
in this second deposition which we
intend to take
prior to trial we intend to ask him many
many
questions under oath he is going to be
compelled to answer them
because he can't uh invoke his fifth
amendment privilege against
self-incrimination hey janice it's tony
decouple
it takes a toll on a person to come
forward in a case like this it takes a
toll on a person to testify
at trial i'm curious knowing what you
know now about the outcome
would you still go back and take the
stand and what would you say to other
women who may be hesitating in different
cases right now
well i would go back in a new york
minute
coming forward actually was empowering
and it gave me strength to speak out
and it also gave me i i received so much
support
that it's kind of like a pay it forward
thing
i have
i just want to help other people and and
not let
this him be released from jail not to
discourage other women
or men from coming forward i have no
problem
speaking my truth and i encourage
everyone to speak their truth because
it's cathartic it's empowering
i feel stronger than i ever did before
and
it's because of the support of all the
survivor sisters
we're this loving group that
will reach out to anyone to help them
come forward like uh
many of us did janice baker kenny and
gloria allred we thank you both for your
time this morning
you're welcome thank you